foreign
Costa and I run Pinnacle Stone
Restoration we are specialized in
restoration of Terrazzo and natural
stone surfaces
I'm going to walk you through how to
restore over 100 years old Terrazzo that
is covered in carpet
[Music]
the most difficult part of this
restoration is carpet and glue removal
we remove carpet with electric scraping
machines
it also can be done by hand but electric
scraping machines do much faster and a
better job
the project is taking place in historic
University dormitory the client decided
to restore existing Terrazzo rather than
replacing carpet costs carpet
accumulates a lot of dust and bacteria
generally Terrazzo is indestructible
surface also it's an easy maintenance
we are discovering multiple issues with
this Terrazzo carpet glue missing
Terrazzo surface cracks and gouge nail
holes it's repairable and requires a lot
of work
the next step we are removing carpet
glue we are removing carpet glue with a
handheld scrapers
versus using grinding process when we
use a grinding process we can activate
the quality of the glue and it will
become sticky but by hand we keep the
temperature low and the glue it just
comes out very easy from terrazzo
then we grind terrazzo floors with
grinding machines we use Diamond discs
we use a coarse medium fine grits to
flatten terrazzoid it's very important
to level and flatten terrazzo floor for
honing process even for polishing
process and this particular project we
are going to use a dry grinding process
just because we want to see the process
during the wet grinding process and the
slurry that is produced during the
grinding prevents us to see the details
of the terrazzo
[Music]
after grinding process is completed we
left with multiple nail holes and cracks
to prepare them for a patchwork we
approach each like a dentist and we
clean them out like in cavity
then Aggregates go into the laws
and when it cures it will be ready to be
grind down to flatten and to level it to
the existing terrazole
the next step of restoration process is
honing which is done with diamond pads
we use water of course to lubricate the
diamonds so lowest grid will be 50 grit
followed by 120 220 400 and 800 Degrees
what only process does it ensures that
no scratches Left Behind the grinding
process
since it's a wet process it will
accumulate a lot of slurry that has to
be extracted by wet vacuums followed by
Edge work
so Edge work is area that bigger
machines don't reach those tight areas
so every step does to happen with
handheld machines in a smaller scales
grinding process to honing process to
reach those tight areas to develop the
same Sheen as rest of the surface
the next step is the polishing is 800
grit completes the honing process 1500
grit starts polishing process so 1500
grit followed by 3000 Grit
and after that we use VIP systems this
is much finer Diamond pads
when you polish Terrazzo you increasing
the density of Terrazzo so it becomes
more durable because you're closing
those poles that's automatically makes
Terrazzo harder and more durable
and now it's time to seal reusing micro
tapping sealer it's more like
impregnating sealer that goes into
Terrazzo and it prevents Terrazzo from
staining and it protects it the last
step is burnishing burnishing helps
sealer to bring the terrazzo to its
highest Gene
if I have to compare this project to
other projects that we've done I would
say this stands for number 10 for sure
because there are a lot of obstacles
that we have to go through and uh
Terrazzo is original and I have to
mention that it's about 5 000 square
feet